hello and welcome to this video playing
cpe Grandmaster cpe who the heck is that
no idea but I writing sperry menteng you
with that Petrosian system yeah what's
ideas is to play in a somewhat
restrained fashion try to limit blacks
activity as far as possible as far as
possible yeah I think you get the drift
ma3 that's a forearm now it is this move
also kind of belongs to the position I
think I know it no he switches to this
idea maybe it wasn't correct I'm fairly
fairly inexperienced in this opening
have only played it I think once and
tournament chess
wonder no 95 maybe to have 94 available
yeah 95 is 48 what I would play but Tim
he probably has a better idea not only
for is pretty annoying something that
probably I could have prevented I still
have the statutory video I don't
understand this I don't have any tasks
going here or whatever pretty weird
still status weird yeah so what is cpe
doing 50 kim jae hmm it's not what I
expected
oh that's right I didn't understand the
Kings Indian properly i guess this looks
completely terrible to me for black and
I mean like completely terrible might be
eight maybe if you allow c6 it's just
over okay you can always blunder stuff
and I tend to do so it he has to do
something now again c6
no okay again I my blunder this position
is totally winning for white I'm not
going to turn them in game or so so
Bishop age 3 is probably a threat some
cover that well I'm just not
understanding the tech correctly that
it's possible of course maybe he has
something really great that I don't get
but I don't I don't see any any real
attack going yeah b5 I don't have to i
can also play quincy for first or
something along these lines no but it's
it's not bad it should win
okay 96 root chicks night if form
probably it's definitely going to be
enough so let's not try to do something
totally fancy just be six I guess check
yeah so that wasn't the most correct way
of doing it I guess
this looks unnecessarily complicated so
c7
it should win right Luke piayed is a
pretty big threat
[Music]
procreate b8 check check black for fits
on time Kim I don't I don't understand
this opening it seems some oh yeah I
think Hugh black was just fine right I
took that looked very okay for me the
night was good on their form but yeah
this is really really took me by
surprise that you took that and then
then and go for this position I that
should be really bad all right okay the
computer kind of Greece like here yeah
okay you can play c6 immediately but g3
is always extremely irritating may it
seems to be correct but I just I just
wanted to play it simple here I justice
allowing c6 I cannot believe maybe he
has nothing there might be a door
something the night is just totally cut
off
some of my stuff fish doesn't get into
reasonable depth Arnold some process
blocking everything in him I just wanted
to wanted to be safe because I mean this
is cut off he's basically playing
without this night and be five at the
right moment is just going to kill black
as it down as it happened in the game k
gym and c7 difficult this opening
position I just I couldn't quite
understand why you would take on e to
hear you can play ever thought OMG 6 + h
5 or whatever it's actually what the
engine gives interesting it's what i
thought during the game yeah somehow
yeah i just think that says excellent
for white when c6 year was even was even
stronger than the game move yeah very
tricky position yeah okay thanks for
watching